welcome to Carnegie Mellon online for
more multimedia from Carnegie Mellon
University
visit
thank you very much thanks Randy
looks like I brought the Beijing weather
with me to Pittsburgh yesterday I gave
the talk from my book so today I'm going
to talk about about Google and Google in
China there are a lot of fascinating
stories and challenges I think every
time I come to America there are only
two kinds of questions one is hey Google
is so great it must be winning in China
everyone must be using it right other
kind this I heard you guys are losing
badly in China are you going to withdraw
like other Internet companies neither
one is quite accurate and today I'll
tell you the environment what we have
done and why we're optimistic so first I
want to talk about the China internet
environment and then I'll talk about
multinationals in China and what
challenges they faced and then talk
about how Google plans to overcome the
challenges and some closing thoughts so
when you think of China they're really
and the role of the internet company
they're really three things China's big
China's challenging and it's a great
marketing it's great and that China is a
great opportunity
China is big which can be shown here the
it's interesting that the trajectory of
Internet users has accelerated not
decelerated this year the recent Chinese
government studies shows that there are
210 million Internet users in China up
from 140 million last year that's a
phenomenon 50 percent 70 million
increase this past year and during this
calendar year the number of Internet
users will surpass the number in the
United States and it will never look
back it will be the largest internet
country for the foreseeable future but
China is really very different all of us
who work on internet would like to think
hey that unites the whole world and to a
certain degree things are similar but in
China things are quite different first
in the US there's a lot of print media
that has a lot of brand and
fame attached to them like Wall Street
Journal New York Times but in China is
much more limited so people really
completely depend on the internet to the
extent that they use the internet for
information so much higher usage those
who start founding the internet love to
use it and depend on it and many just
don't even read print media average age
in China is 25 Internet user and it's uh
it's dropping every year it what can't
happen forever but
it has been for some time and that means
the age gap means people are on it
looking for fun stuff entertainment
community playing games so those become
popular applications the internet cafe
usage is accounts for about a third of
the Chinese usage largely again from the
youths
in the US iTunes iPod that's where
everybody gets the music but in China
they actually use a search engine our
largest competitor called Baidu where
they find music that some typically free
download and
they usually bring it to a PC and listen
to it and of course increasing people
have mp3s that look really very much
like an iPod and they enjoy the music
there so how to make money can be
difficult software piracy is high if
that's going to come down over time but
for a company like my former employer
that's a pretty tough problem but for
Google we see the opportunity because
well if we can provide high quality free
software as a service that could really
attract a lot of people the credit card
usage is two orders of magnitude smaller
than the u.s. here we have two per
person there is two per hundred people
and that means ecommerce is very
difficult it doesn't mean there isn't
ecommerce lots of things are being
searched for on the internet but the
transaction takes place in real person
common examples are you go to an eBay
like site bid for something when it's
done you go meet the seller and buy it
after you examine the product okay
another example is you buy it from an
Amazon like company except that you
don't have to pay the person some a
delivery person next day on the bicycle
brings the merchandise to your home you
examine it and then you pay so cash on
delivery Internet as a way to find what
you want but physical is the way you
transact appears to be the way to go now
of course eventually credit cards will
take on but that could take and the
number of years and the last difference
I'll highlight here is that a number of
mobile phones has reached a 510 million
more than twice the internet population
so among many implications is that when
internet on mobile phone becomes a
reality most of the users who experience
it will have never touched a PC before
and that means where the u.s. mobile
phone internet mobile internet is
evolving which is can it synchronize
with my PC cannot download and update my
contact list synchronize my email those
are not issues to a large number of
users there because it'll be a mobile
centric PCs may be an afterthought or a
future
purchase opportunity so all of these
differences require any company that
wants to be successful in the internet
or software business really embrace that
these differences and build products
that fit the market and China is
challenging so in addition to these
different market situations there are a
lot of laws which are different laws
about content laws about requiring a
license to do internet portal here
acquiring a license or search limiting
news and video to Chinese state-owned
entities etc that makes it rather
difficult for internet companies
especially in areas that are heavily
regulated to enter China secondly sorry
thirdly there's a it's a very nascent
legal environment so the how to enforce
the things like mp3 copyrights is still
not well understood
courts have different rulings and it
will say take some time for that to
stabilize and become consistently
enforceable number four is that there is
a lot of local competitors who move very
fast who are very aggressive and they
have a lot of cash where does their cash
come from American venture capitalists
who have now found China as the growing
market so let's go fund the company that
is building something in the like of
Google like an MSN Messenger like an
eBay like anything like a Facebook and
there are many such companies like a
YouTube that are coming out there are
some 20 YouTube clones and maybe 3 or 4
Facebook clones
not to mention this for those search
companies and so on and there are
well-funded because you know when you
raise ten million dollars in the US you
spend it pretty quickly but that amount
of money lasts a really long time in
China and there's their practices are
very aggressive they build products very
quickly and they also take on rather
aggressive practices for example to
compete against eBay a local company
called Taobao decided we're going to do
exactly what eBay offers except
there's no fees no listing fees so very
quickly they took market share away
while burning a lot of cash but they
have now become the dominant player and
they'll figure out how to make money
later and just to be fair to them they
have figured out a way which is escrow
payments which is very very clever also
so these companies are clever they are
not just copycats they're very smart
people building in increasingly
innovative products that may be inspired
by American successes but localize
quickly with a lot of talent and cash
behind it so multinationals do have a
hard time because there's genuine
competition it's not just the legal or
other issues and lastly the internet
media being so new is fairly easily
manipulated so sometimes people will
just spread false rumors and it spreads
very quickly in the internet space and
you never really know whether it's your
competitor disgruntled employee or just
someone who wants to be famous that's
spreading the rumor so that can really
hurt someone who's trying to participate
by the normal international professional
ethical practices such as Google and
other multinationals because we
obviously do not use such such medium so
these are some of the reasons China's
challenging so you might say wow it's a
big opportunity but it's so different
and so challenging
so can a multinational succeed certainly
if past histories and the indication the
road to success is definitely fraught
with difficulties so I'll give you a few
examples that multinational struggles in
China I'll do it in chronologically
Yahoo was earliest to enter China in
1999 they spend some 150 million dollars
or so on the company called 30721 and
then they drifted from about a third
market share much to much lower
eventually they sold the shares to
Alibaba which proves to be very valuable
however Yahoo China has suffered large
loss and recently announced the layoffs
and their market share is in the low
single digits AOL another example that
enter very early they did a joint
venture with Lenovo very powerful
accessible Chinese company they build a
portal but it was shut down three years
later eBay entered in 2003 I told you
about the Chinese free competitor very
hard to compete against free and
eventually they sold their China
presents to Tom and their market share
is also very very low fourth example is
Amazon they entered the Chinese company
by buying the number one a company at
the time called Julie oh by the way eBay
also bought the number one auction
company because they saw the
difficulties earlier companies had they
figured well it's by a local Chinese
company and have them run our operations
but that doesn't really work either
because there's a lot of you know
platform issues which platform do you
use how do you communicate with
headquarters etc that led to very large
share loss so now there are rather
distant number two in terms of selling
merchandise and books msn entered in
2004 i mean i think they may have
spawned between venture in 2005 in
instant messaging there are still a
number two but in terms of their core
business of portal and search they're
not even in top 5 and that means
somewhere around 1 percent or so market
share wikipedia another
another big success in America and not
accessible in China so if you look at
these probably the you know other than
Google the other top five or six
companies in the internet space you can
see why I stay up very late at night
worried about the problems I talked to
you about now I'm not ready to claim
victory but certainly we can't claim
defeat we entered in 2006 myspace
entered in 2007 and for these two
companies I think is too early to tell
but today Baidu has a much larger market
share than we do they have been
successful not just in search but
they're also the number one community
product number one music product and the
number one question answering products
and they offer what's called Baidu pedia
which is very much like
like a product with a similar name
myspace I think you arguably that's a
new area but really there's a really if
you think about that their real
competitor is actually QQ which is an
instant message but is a very clever
instant message it's instant message
micro payments animated avatars and
social networks all rolled into one
with lots of Chinese features you know
you can build closed groups for
discussion that others can't see you can
have private chats you can have an
avatar and they sell avatar clothing and
they make lots of mainland payments
through that you know you if you might
think well that's silly who would pay
for clothing for avatar they have very
clever marketing approach they first use
first start as an avatar wearing a
t-shirt and then one day you're offered
a free upgrade to any one of the
following attire for free trial for 3
months so of course you accept and three
months later when the free trial expires
you become a half naked person
unless of course you pay you know 30
cents a month which is fairly cheap and
most people do and once you do that you
become enchanted with you know buying
flowers and cakes and what-have-you and
all this all this virtual merchandise
becomes very popular I talked with the
CEO of another company similar to QQ and
he says well we just rolled out virtual
cakes and it's very successful I asked
him how much do you sell it for
he said well about the same as real
cakes in the real world so so it's a
very different environment and
undoubtedly we have challenges but why
have these comes companies have trouble
I think all the challenges are listed
earlier but also I think a lot of
multinationals wanted to make money
let's go in there new China CEO
here's your quarterly profit target go
reach it do whatever it takes but that
causes problems it optimizes for the
short term doesn't build a company to
last and so on the local team is not
empowered okay we hired you you ran the
local sales team but we're going to do
all the engineering from the US and you
can imagine it's hard to keep up with
the rapidly changing environment when
every request has to be translated to
English and wait for the teams to
prioritize especially if China is not
high revenue in the beginning third one
is system global platform you know we
bought the company and if someone a
company bought another company in China
and says well your product yours your
platform doesn't look built to last
let's cancel your platform and use the
US platform without realizing that
platform has implications that makes it
hard to build features needed for China
local partnerships going along say while
we're number one in the US we're going
to be number one in China we don't need
any partners we can take on everybody
and anybody that's not very smart you
need all the friends you can have in any
environment including China and lastly
just slower moving more processes more
strategy more decision layers and that
can cause slower moving companies these
are some of the problems so when Google
decided to go to China when I decided to
take this job these are the some
the key points that I thought were
really important and before I accepted
the job I had a lot of discussions with
Eric and Larry and Sergey to make sure
that we will have a chance to execute on
the strategy so that we can become
successful and the following eight
things are the things that I'll now tell
you about first I think is you really
need a long-term view and patience and
that's actually always true if you look
at the other industries the companies
that have been successful in China
whether it's whether it's Aldi but they
actually have the number one market
share in cars or motorola they've been
number one in the cell phones for a long
time and even now they're had to head
against Nokia despite the few no Nokia
might have pulled ahead in products is
that they've really shown its sincerity
to build local operations run by local
employees and to give and to build
strategically and worry about making
money later and I think that's no
different in any other in any other area
I think we all would much prefer even
America prefer foreign companies that
come to America build an auto plan try
to understand the consumers build
products that make sense for the
marketplace rather than ones that just
want in come in to make a quick buck so
that makes a lot of sense it's not just
good for China it's good anywhere but
certainly in China those who have had
the longer term patience even if they
don't have the very best product that's
been quite important so we decided to
take the following plan and these are
words from Eric Schmidt he said we will
take a long term view to win in China
Chinese have a 5,000 years of history
and Google has 5000 years of patience
and these words are very comforting to
me when I joined even though I
I'm not play I'm not planning a life
expectancy yeah but that long and I
think that that's important obviously
it's an exaggerated statement but I
think it really shows that's the
attitude it takes to become successful
so our long-term view is roughly in the
following manner
when we went in in late 2005 2006 we
didn't worry about how to make money we
were losing market share at the time we
didn't worry about well how to fix that
what should we build how do we you know
do something how do we stop that we
thought hey it's important to fix the
product you can't buy market share when
the product is good the market sure will
come later so how do you build good
products well you got to hire the people
so we work backwards and said well hey
if we hire the people now build the R&D
center it's gonna take a while before
our product became really really good
and we're gonna lose market share until
that happens and we accepted that
reality rather than rushing in to get
people to use a product that might not
suit their needs or make money before
the time this was was due so we decided
to really focus on people build hire
great people though the world-class team
that can build products that are
suitable locally and it's an R&D center
made up of Chinese people who understand
the needs in the market place so that
the products will be naturally locally
compatible and appropriate
then once the we take a whole year and
build up a Grade Center then we can
start developing products so you know
seven and now going on Oh eight in the
last year and this year what we want to
do is have undisputedly the best Chinese
search and we know we have the best
English search but we got to have the
best Chinese search not just in search
quality but also in search experience
secondly we should come out with a lot
of products that surprise people how
Chinese it is by focusing and
understanding on Chinese user needs and
building products to suit their needs
and by adding features to our worldwide
products I think that's another second
important step and then we want to
partner extensively because we're a very
we're a very focused company on search
so many other companies like portals and
mobile companies are very happy to work
with us because we have no con
collective interests and they can really
help us greatly in entering markets
understanding customers and lastly
market share and profit will follow and
certainly where we've done a pretty good
job on a lot of this and we're start
seeing that market share is turning
around
we have been gaining market share for
the past eight or nine months and we
hope profitability will happen soon also
but not because we started with that as
the first task but that's really the end
result not the thing that we focus on
and somewhere between before seven
thousand and six we hope to do all those
things too and that's of course again a
joke some people ask me will it really
be 5,000 years before you'll be success
become successful of course not I think
if we have a good strategy and iterate
on the top six things good things will
happen much much earlier so let me now
talk about each of those six things so
here I mentioned one two three four five
six
I will now spend maybe five to ten
minutes on each one okay so people first
Eric Schmidt has said our growth is
limited not by market opportunities your
competitive challenges but by whether or
not we can find world's greatest
engineers and challenging them with
world's toughest problems and that's our
global approach to hiring lot lots of
people who are really really smart and
empowering them and trusting them to
come up with the next innovation and are
approaching in China is really no
different of course China has a much
larger labor pool so we have to have a
very scalable recruiting process so how
do you attract talent let Google are we
basically offer a couple of things that
are quite unique one is that we you can
change the world in a lot of companies
but at Google our product cycles are six
months so you can see your impact sooner
second thing is people who computer
scientists engineers tend to be very
hands-on they don't want to just write
very high-level UI around predefined
them product market needs they want to
invent everything themselves so at
Google we can really invent everything I
always give as an example that we're not
just doing information
but we actually build everything our own
databases our own file systems we modify
Linux to be our own operating systems
and we even build servers so in without
you know your 9999 these are their early
servers that our team built because
Google's problems are too tough for they
for then existing commercial servers can
see we make lots of mistakes and correct
them along the way see here we have the
wires in the back of the server so every
time you have to change the virus you
have to flip everything around and we
learn quickly from mistakes you can see
that in 2000 all the wires and in the
front of the servers now but you see
this additional interesting equipment
called cooling units or otherwise
otherwise known as a fan because we
forgot about cooling so we put that in
and of course in 2002 we fixed that too
and we can in just three days configure
a data center okay I know this is an
important area for CMU that's moving
into as well and that's really one of
the prized assets that was only made
possible because we let in our engineers
dream the impossible dream and be
empowered to tackle any problem
themselves and that's very compelling to
engineers worldwide we give from
engineers a lot of freedom one examples
20% of the time can be spent on the
project of their choice not the project
to which they're assigned we value
technologists not just managers the
often people say the most prized title
at Google is software engineer because
they have the most freedom and the most
fun forge in China we actually provide
development opportunities for people in
our who enter China we actually offer to
send them to the u.s. up to half of
their time and we even pay for their
master's degree training in computer
science if they don't have a master's
and we've become the number one place to
work we've seen that for the United
States and it's clearly true for
computer scientists students almost
everywhere in the world and certainly
including China if you do a survey at
the top universities clearly everybody
every engineer views some Google to be
the top place to work and that's really
a great start that gives us a chance our
culture really is what I just described
but people often talk about oh your work
environment so much fun and good food
that really is secondary but just for
completeness I'll show you our China
work environment and you can see it's
really quite similar to our Pittsburgh
or New York or Mountain View offices
this is our Google building located
right next to Ching Wan University in
Beijing this is our lobby this is our a
party that we had you can see we have
Chinese elements like bahding the eye of
the dragon dragon and we have a big
party with lots of good food our work
environment is as colorful as anywhere
you see both Western cultural symbols as
well as Eastern cultural symbols and
people really have a lot of fun and
people also work not just have fun they
work really hard and they play very hard
you can see here we have the western
elements of a gym and then the eastern
elements of karaoke and we also have the
western elements of football and pool
and now the increasingly eastern
elements of dance dance revelution and
of course the most important part is to
win an engineer's heart have to win his
or her stomach and this is the food
that's available in our cafe so
we have an interesting feature on our
Google search called related search
that's when you type a search term we
suggest all the related search terms so
for example if you type something like
Hillary Clinton you might say you might
see you know Hillary Clinton's platform
Hillary Clinton's debate Hillary
Clinton's status in the poll so it's
Google suggests and if you type Google
cafe in in China we will suggest the
term is how to get a free lead meal at
Google cafe that's determined
automatically by the searches so a lot
of people in China are searching for
ways to get a free meal
in our cafe and that's our most
important employee our executive chef
and of course all that aside we really
have to focus on what do we actually do
to hire these great people but we got to
have a giant recruiting team so we have
lots of people in our recruiting team we
build up offices where there's talent so
we have offices in Beijing Taipei and
Shanghai and we want to bring the Google
culture so we hire them
we brought 30 people from Mountain View
New York Kirkland to move over to China
and also we do a lot of local hiring and
we really hire a lot of really start
like talents like the ACM champion top
students in a lot of schools we keep the
hiring bar very high completely
consistent with the with the US but we
also reduce the bars that are not so
important because we consider all
interviews completely exclusively in
Chinese we don't want the fact that a
great engineer doesn't speak good
English let him or her not get into
Google and then we can always teach them
English later and we have internship
programs and these are some pictures
that you see here so that's what people
first is about the first year we really
focus we hire great people made them
have fun build a great environment all
the time all during the time when we
were losing market share and that's a
very courageous challenging but
strategic thing to do so that really
pays off in 2007 when all these people
were ready to start eager feeling very
valued by the company very excited to be
in the environment
new technologies so let's go build so
when we build we also do things very
differently so we do real R&D and what
does that really mean when people talk
about R&D in China really they're
talking about one of these things
localizing American products doing
testing solution centers consulting
outsourcing and there's one noted
example of a great research lab doing
great publications something I was
involved in many years ago and these are
examples of R&D in China but they're not
really equivalent to doing R&D in their
counterpart office in the US so Google's
R&D is this is not just for China but
for every one of our over 40 R&D centers
worldwide we wanted to go where talent
is but we also want them to understand
the local market build products that are
suitable for local market and then
globalize those products for the rest of
the world so our initial distribution
was we because we're so far behind in
the in China most of the energy was
focused on China products with less
global balance but we just met with the
team recently and while I wanted the
team to do is is they asked me what's
the balance between building China
products and global products well I said
well we have a hundred percent at a time
you should spend ninety percent building
China products and 60 percent building
global products and that's not
suggesting people should work 150
percent as hard that's really saying
when you build Chinese products keep the
globalization in mind and when you build
global products keep the Chinese needs
in mind so that your efforts can be
doubly leveraged and the way we build
products worldwide probably a lot of
people have seen this we really let
people have a lot of freedom to try new
things when people have a new idea we
have an ideas list that people can vote
on when things are very popular
naturally a group of people bottom-up
without manager approval get together
and build something we focus on the user
and we'll do anything that solves user
problems and help organize the world's
information so I think the approach we
take very much matches the the internet
and we do that the same way in every R&D
center throughout the world so to build
a new product often you start with the
new idea
and you sent it out to an IV list people
vote I like it I don't like it if nobody
likes it usually you killed the idea
yourself out of self-awareness and if if
people like the idea you tell them hey
don't just vote with your hands vote
with your feet come to me and we'll
build the prototype together so two or
three Google engineers will try a
prototype then they'll launch it
internal in the company see if people
like it they don't then of course the
product is gone they do like it we'll do
something bigger and put in Google Apps
measure use the internet to measure user
response they like it we build into a
product if they don't then we don't
continue with it and then the innovative
person then spends 20% time on the next
thing then the cycle continues and this
is really very exciting to the engineers
draws them to the company and we think
that's what will fuel the company and
keep it innovative even as some of our
earlier technologies may become
commoditized over time we always think
of new things and third is okay now that
we have great people and we have a great
environment and we follow the world
where our Indy model what do they build
or the first thing we got a bill is
great Chinese search because that's what
most Chinese search for 95% of searches
in China are in Chinese only a small
percentage are in foreign languages so
we've got to make sure we're matching
local content very well building search
is obviously very core to us because
that's the number one value proposition
people that need to find stuff that's
the key source of people going to the
site and then finding things from there
it's also the number one revenue
generator for the company and it's not
sticky
that means if something people don't
like our search they'll go to someone
else's and vice versa it's not quite
like a PC or a cellphone or an operating
system once you use it the switching
cost is very high search engine
switching cost is theoretically quite
low so if you build a better at widget
other people's will come to you so
that's why we feel we gotta really build
a better widget and then we all attract
more people so how do we develop the
best Chinese search well first there's
the traditional metrics you know is it
relevant is it fresh is a hike
coverage is it fast and does it have
spam so we've done a lot of work we
build data centers that reduce our
latency improved our access we've
developed higher quality Chinese search
and these are third part estimates that
show we have better search results than
any other search engine we're also
developing Chinese linguistic
technologies you may have heard some
claims about one by two by languages
Chinese languages being hard there's a
tiny bit of truth in that
but not not a whole lot I'll just give
you one example that we have to do some
work in and that's a segmentation so for
example if I were to type the following
phrase into a word processor or a search
engine one of the big issues you might
notice is that there's no white space
and that's kind of like being able to do
this to be able to parse or search this
and that seems difficult so your
intuition might be hey just cut it up
you know Carnegie Mellon University that
seems like Oh like one linguistic unit
but it's not that simple if you cut it
up if you just cut it up according to
linguistic units then you Carnegie
Mellon University is one unit and you
search for Carnegie Mellon you might not
match it if you cut it up too little
then actually Carnegie Mellon means in
Chinese is five characters with five
distinct meanings than your matching
spurious things that my match
com a and B it shouldn't
so segmentation is in fact a problem and
how do you deal with that is a challenge
that we face but coming back to the real
problem it's really not that hard
compared to building a global search
platform this is perhaps 5% of the work
or less and we've in the past year or
two we've completed that work and that
our segmentation works great and and
it's been overcome and it's done move on
to the next problem so it's definitely
not the case that Chinese or two by
languages have some mysterious
difficulty most of the intelligence is
statistical and it works for every
language developing a fast index this is
just an example shows that a new article
can be indexed by us in seven minutes
that means you can search for and find
it and another is developed
and better snippets so when you see the
search results snip it off to match the
search in a more relevant way
bottom shows another search engine with
less relevant result so that's the hard
work we put in I mean it's easy the hand
wave and say oh this is accurate faster
or better better snippet Chinese
processing but it really was you know
something like 100 engineers working
hard for one or two years tweaking every
little element so we're now at the point
where the our Chinese search is visibly
and clearly more accurate than other
search engines then the gap is no
smaller than our lead in say English
language in the United States so that
was a lot of work to come in from behind
and really take a clear leadership
position and we think that leadership
position is sustainable because we're
going to keep working at it
and tweaking everything we can to
provide an accurate search experience
well on any one given search us we may
win or lose if you really do five or ten
searches you'll see that our results
really are consistently better the
second thing is actually much more
challenging just getting better accuracy
is a very scientific research oriented
process for which Google is very suited
the second part is well what do the
Chinese users need our and they actually
need something a little bit different
than the other users that we have seen
in the US and I'll give you an example
we did an eye tracking study the results
are quote actually is from a third party
study but we also did it internally eye
tracking study that says show choke to
let people do search and track their eye
movements see what part of the page they
look at it turns out in the US people
look at the result page only ten seconds
in China it's 30 to 60 seconds okay much
longer why is that why do they look at
it longer than we did that eye tracking
study and we found that actually this is
a third party did this work they found
that in the US when you do a search
people look at the upper left corner the
top one or two or three results they
click they find what they want their
done but in Chinese they're clicking
they're looking all over the place so
it's an inherently cultural difference
causes that behavior and it's quite
dramatic as you as you can see here and
what causes that I think that has very
much to do with the fact that the
Chinese users really are thirsty for
information and they're very curious to
learn more and they're searching not
with the goal of just finding but
exploring and learning so in the u.s. a
typical search behaviors I want to find
something I know the thing I want to
find I don't know what it is but I'll
know it when I see it I typed the term
that will get me there I click on
results until I find it then I close all
windows undone but in the Chinese search
a typical thing is I heard of X which is
really interesting
let me type the term and see what I got
Oh everything looks interesting I'm
gonna click on every result
and then they read them and they read
everything and they absorb it like
sponge thirsty for information now to be
for full disclosure when I say
information most of the information is
entertainment okay but there is
knowledge as well but the general
behavior you can see here is really very
very dramatic so we've did a user study
at the time we did it with Baidu search
engine this isn't intended to say
they're good or bad it's just that we
did the study based on their search
engine we asked people go look for a map
of the Ching Wong island it's a resort
island so people we thought they would
type Ching Wan Island right and then
just get it we thought they would type
Ching Wan island map and be done with it
but instead they just typed Ching Wan
Island then they get all the search
results and they skipped completely they
scroll to the bottom which shows you
related search results and as they look
at all those interesting things I'm
gonna the development area the
information island the the hiring real
estate people jobs and then they click
on a bunch of them including the map ok
so that's very interesting behavior so
why do they do all this stuff and
there's lots of reasons but one of them
is really just that their curiosity and
thirst for knowledge
so suggesting more things that people
might want to click on helping them to
satisfy that thirst for information or
entertainment is very important so how
can Google develop products that will
help make that happen so we also
developed a we actually always have we
always have a related search but here we
suggest more things here it's searching
for an actress name and it says you know
this actress is Shanghai concerts his
pictures his video his his discussion
his fan bar his blog his sorry not his
her hurt her
her Chinese side her concerts her niece
you know and people are just going wild
this is so much fun I click on
everything what's about her knees it's
her knees becoming a famous movie star
too so people just click on everything
and we also create a categories of
results so whenever you search for any
automobile you will see automobile
reviews automobile reliability
automobile prices things that are highly
relevant for that domain and why provide
search suggestions after they search why
not provided as they type so as you type
in this particular example it will show
the results without you typing further
so saves you typing it shows the results
as you type every letter you type more
suggestions come up lots of servers
traffic lots of servers we have to buy
but it's ok because users want it we
also provide well here the don't worry
about just the things you search a lot
what are other people searching what are
other people clicking on what are
Americans clicking on what are Japanese
users searching for here's all the
things everybody's searching for so you
know have a party we also put these
popular search queries as ads
advertising on other people's websites
to entice people to try out our search
engine but also entice them to satisfy
the thirst for information we provide a
shallow directory of all the types of
information you might want to look for
we work with internet cafes and we put
all kinds of clickable things on it
where people can click to search and we
also make clicking for new search easier
you can click on images and see and see
what's up
so what happens when people want go back
to the earlier user studies example what
happens when people want to look for
Ching Wong Ching Wong Island map or they
would still type 2 yuan down but before
they have a chance to look at the
results roll down and relate a search
all the related searches that are
already so they can just click on map as
the first results then they get to
Google Maps directly so now just three
clicks away from from the information
even if you type and under specified
search term there are the reasons that
people don't type because typing is very
difficult
you have to map English characters to
Chinese characters and is inherently
ambiguous so if you type shishi
into Chinese don't try to pronounce that
don't try this at home it's very hard to
pronounce it could actually map to
anyone that following things should
issue out and I'll let you fill the
blanks they all sound the same to you
but they all mean different things in
Chinese so typing is quite difficult so
resolving that ambiguity how do you
resolve the ambiguity I can see the
researchers who are thinking how about
language model how about machine
learning or that's exactly what it takes
so Google took all the Chinese data that
we have and build a gigantic language
model that map's things to the proper
shoe shoe on your type shoe
based on the previous words that
occurred and it's you know diagram
Engram language model that works very
well because we crawl a giant text we
also know the latest words say somebody
became a famous yesterday we'll know
that term because the frequently
searched term and we'll push that term
to your computer so that your dictionary
is updated every day and you can of
course have your own personalized
dictionary and we actually let you
access it from any machine so this is
got huge number tens and millions of
downloads in Chinese one of the hottest
software that's a client product and the
third reason people don't type is they
can't spell and that problem hurts
Google in many ways we've asked people
hey have you heard of company called
Google oh yeah of course you know that
exciting American company building
really cool search products it works
well in English did you know works in
Chinese oh no you want to try it okay
spell it
geo geo tou geo you say no no goog le
but it doesn't match the Chinese
spelling so we said okay let's have a
chinese name called
google which it sounds like Google and
you can spell to ug but that's still
kind of weird people have already got
used to Google what's this Chinese name
all about some people are not easy don't
have an easy time remember to ug so we
said okay we'll make it really easy and
we've introduced
what so those of you who might want to
go acquire all the one letter domain
names is not available in com only
available in dot C n so we were
fortunate to have had the opportunity to
buy that early
and the next is how to do a good search
well we have to organize all kinds of
content so our company vision is
organize the world's information search
does a good job to organize text and
does all kinds of clever things with
text search but really Larry and Sergey
have always encouraged us to think about
the ultimate search engine that
understands what you mean gives you what
you want in any format period media
language user place and time so as a
result we work on making actually I
don't know if you know this but you can
try Google CNN for Chinese Google that
us for us Google that JP for Japan and
all of them are not the language but
their location the ranking are according
to the users preference for that
location so interestingly you can search
for English on a dot cm page or or the
Us page and it's all works with any
language in any location machine
translation is another big challenge a
lot of Chinese users would love to find
content this is an example of taking the
Harry Potter page and translating
automatically using our machine
translation which is trained on Chinese
huge amounts of parallel Chinese English
data you can see on this curve the more
data we feed it the better it gets
and we crawl a lot of bilingual texts so
just for fun I'll show you one example
of translation so in this example it
shows a super girl phenomenon which is a
huge phenomenon in China it's it's
American Idol it's Chinese Idol if you
will and if you type this name in
Chinese and say let's translate it
English okay this is the translation
supergirls five finally settle after a
heated rivalry phase she shed tears at
the stage okay not perfect but you get
the idea you know it's the finalist five
and then she didn't get picked so she
cried the translation is very hard
ours is certainly not perfect but we
took the second best machine translation
off the internet see what they did this
is what they said ultra female chung
passes through the intense contention
finally dust of all the sides
CFA
she fail a sprinkles the stage so those
of you who know Chinese you can see that
they took each Chinese character and
translated to English and glued it
together which of course results in
completely garbled meaning this is not
to claim that we're always this good are
always this much better this more just a
fun example and of course we also
capture real-time news we grab news
information every few minutes and it's
put it put this resulted not only in our
new search but our generic search we
also have search of archives so old
search results can show up and we have
all kinds of content finance content
books content all over the place video
content image content map content we
think all of that should work very very
well indeed individually and it has to
work in any location so any web page we
intelligently on the mobile to accessing
through mobile will translated to an
appropriate format so that's what we try
to do to get every part information to
be searchable so now that helps us build
a good image search new search book
search and so on archive search but not
everybody knows each of the vertical
search engines so we have a global
initiative called Universal Search that
says hey all of those vertical results
they ought to be aggregated into one
result so if you go to one search box
that should get you anything so
Universal Search really means in the
past is one search box from one index
but today people are doing more and more
vertical searches they might be done
about product search image search book
search and so on because they tend to be
more accurate than the generic search
because they're able to for example
scholar search can look at the quality
of citations that point to your your
particular publication while our web
search isn't going to know that but our
revelation is that well we can keep
having a great scholar search in book
search and image search but really
people want one search so all of those
things should be indexable into one
index and searchable from one box so the
idea you can think of it is let's say
there are 300 vertical searches and our
type of query
that query is asked to the 300 people
say hey who knows something about this
query that maybe 10 them and raise their
hand I know something then the search
engine would analyze okay for this user
doing this search at this time which of
the 10 is most credible and then we
would blend the result into a universal
search results so as an example if you
search for bird nests in China bird
nests doesn't mean the nest of a bird it
actually is the Olympic Stadium you can
see here the image search results are
the top because a lot of users are
curious what does it look like
and the news is very tough and then
other things will search web search
results follow but easily you can
imagine 2 or 3 years from now when the
bird nest stadium is not that hot
anymore this image search will no longer
show up so it's dynamically intelligent
and adjust itself so that's what we plan
to do with Chinese search all of the
products I talked abouts already
shipping and that's really helped us
gain market share with just have
building a better widget then next is
really understanding Chinese users and
building not just search products but
any products that users want in order to
to win their hearts and their minds and
build a stronger brand so what do
Chinese users want I talked about
communities entertainment because the
users almost half as young as United
States so we've launched several
products one is a Chinese orchid called
Lai bomb when is Google Answers
re-adopted for China Chinese called
winda and when this video search taken
from worldwide but applied to China and
in all of these products we're thinking
about globally so in went on for example
similar addition has already launched in
Russia and more versions were launched
later that's how we want to take
mountain view technologies launch them
in China build new technology and let
other geographies build on top of that
and we also think a lot of the
community's entertainment theme is going
to be very similar in not just China but
also in the Vietnam Russia a lot of the
developing countries so we like to think
our work can benefit lots of developing
countries as well
client software products I said is very
popular so we're building lots of client
software products and hoping that they
will build up Google brand and of course
there will be a small number of searches
from these products and they will point
to Google and bring more customers to
try our products I talked a little bit
about within City search and that people
look online but that but that they
transact locally and geographically
there is no Craigslist's that's dominant
no yellow pages that's high quality so
we aspire to partner to build all of
this with ourselves and with our
partners so Google Maps certainly worked
in China but we also find that people
don't just want to go to a place they
want to do something they want to go to
a restaurant the Chinese people often
talk about food clothing living and
transportation as the core of life so in
this search people want to look for
what's fun what's good food what's a
good shopping what's a good house what's
a good apartment what's a good job and
we provide what's lifestyle search which
searches specific databases and gives
very accurate results those are products
that we have launched mobile phones
they're everywhere we start by building
search on mobile but also Maps is
obviously very relevant and this was
image news and many products so our
mobile is rising very very rapidly and
we also partner with China mobile as
well as enable web results to be sent to
phone because it's very silly remember
see that back in the days when we had to
look for a map and print it out and
carry it into a car now GPS is starting
to be more popular but but in China
printing out is still a pain why not
just send the entire result to your
phone so if you want to look for a
restaurant or a location we provide SMS
directly from any search result map
result to be sent to your phone so that
we connect your PC and phone usage
without forcing you to use 3G or mobile
Internet and we also enable SMS search
SMS there are billion SMS is every day
in China and we basically let people SMS
to our
Foam service which has a machine as
sending search results back and it
doesn't do general search it's a search
that's related to things people might
need when they're on the road mobile
looking for location map store hours
restaurant reviews and the like so those
are the kind of products we're building
mobile community entertainment and we
hope they'll win the hearts of Chinese
users and then we partner extensively we
realize we can't be successful on our
own so we partner with lots of companies
their businesses are not directly
related to ours so we partner with
portals the top or the two portals in
China seen on Tencent both use our
search we have mobile partnerships China
mobile and 3G Internet are three of two
of the top companies with more partner
with ISPs in many ways we partner with
client software products browsers
communities books and we use a lot of
resellers to help resell our advertising
solutions and that really creates a very
positive cycle of partners and that will
create many people who will be out there
doing things that fit their business
need but also promote our products our
brand our usage our as in our search and
that's really helped our growth in the
past year a great deal and we believe
market share and profit will follow
there's not really a precise strategy
Google has a very interesting business
where as our traffic doubles our revenue
is likely to also double so we really
just take advantage of that and really
focus on building the traffic and let
the dollars follow so this curve shows
on the worldwide basis this green curve
is the market share worldwide and then
the blue curve shows the revenue you can
see that as our early days that we just
focus on market share and as market
share got to a certain critical mass
revenue came later and we are able to
rely on the same thing everywhere else
so that's a very unique formula that
allows us to really focus on the user on
what they need even though they don't
pay us but later ads will show up more
and more on searches there are more
searches as show up
or and it will get a multiplicative
effect of the revenue and transactions
that result so those are the product
plans that we have one step at a time
and lastly I wanted to talk about
empowerment of local team because when I
spoke of other multinationals and the
challenges they faced often theirs they
took they really didn't have a team
locally that they could say you make
that decision I trust you you go build
that product it's ok to deviate from the
corporate product line or fork the code
because this is important enough there
were less willing to do that because if
every country did that it would be a
very messy situation but if we had a
strong team in China that follows the
worldwide development processes and that
judiciously makes decisions say when to
fork the code when to create a new sales
channel and the team is consistent with
corporate values and principles and is
trusted then it can move more nimbly and
then we can compete more effectively so
how do you get a headquarter of any
company to empower you whether you're in
China or India or anywhere that's a key
issue for any subsidiary of any
multinational company I think a very key
thing is for the differences I've
articulated to you in the past hour to
be understood and internalized by the
CEO and key decision-makers in
headquarters so it's really important to
get people in the headquarters to come
and visit China and not just listen to
the words I've spoken but see for
themselves that the market is unique
different challenging growing and full
of opportunities so we've sponsored a
number of executive visits this is Eric
coming to China having breakfast with
American ambassador to China who
resonated with a lot of the points that
I would make this is our heads of legal
and engineering visiting universities we
brought a lot of executives to Beijing
University to talk to students here is
Jeff Dean our chief scientist talking to
students in China understanding the
users this is the head of our crawling
group this is Marissa Mayer our VP of
products talking to really excited young
people learning about
marketplace so to help understand why
China is the way it is we also have
employees reenact some of the past
histories so to the extent there's a you
know sense of a glory and pride well
that's because during the Qin Dynasty
during the Chen long times that general
Emperor right there
also known as Steve Googler number
whatever three hundred and reenacting
this is why the Chinese people feel a
particular sense of pride and patriotism
and Cultural Revolution what effects
that might have on today's society and
we also try to reenact that with our
young Googler engineers the economic
market ization right while the political
system is reforming more slowly the
market the marketing economy is embraced
with complete openness and that's led to
people who have high aspiration that
American Dream is really now the Chinese
dream and these are some of the early
aspires in China and how does the
Chinese government work these are people
doing a mock-up of a Chinese
parliamentary debate to understand how
to talk to the Chinese government
officials and these are the various
Mountainview executives learning
watching and having fun at all the
little skits that we put up and this is
the entire delegation dressed in not
Chinese uniform and this picture is very
interesting during one of the visits I
took Eric to one of the Chinese
ministries she met with this official
who came up afterwards and said I'm a
big Google fan you know how I can prove
it look at this picture
my cat's name Google
she said my last cat was named Yahoo
all factual not making any of this up
and once you get the headquarters to
trust you I think you got to build up
credibility to show that yes we have to
be flexible but we're not asking to
break every rule we're certainly going
to hold up corporate values and we're
going to understand that corporate
mission is larger than the local mission
and we have to make up some successes
built up but build up some successes and
win trust and hire people who are
trusted and trustworthy and trusted then
over time the local team will get a lot
of empowerment to build products
businesses partnerships sales and
channels the way it needs to get done
and those are the steps that we paint
painstakingly step by step did starting
in late 2005 when I was hired throughout
2006 and in 2007 were seeing definite
results this is a Wall Street Journal
article where Eric very specifically
said that he plans to give the China
unit more greater autonomy as a result
of the progress that we have made from
2006 to mid 2007 and since then we've
really made a lot of local product
decisions we've improved search a great
deal and we've significantly increase
our search volume as well our market
share and we're definitely not an
uptrend but the road is definitely still
full of challenges and we look forward
to to overcoming them so in closing I
think the multinationals definitely face
a lot of challenges but Google really
tries to overcome them and we're
optimistic about it why is that one
because we think we have tremendous
company assets technology leadership and
brand we feel the company has made a
serious and long-term commitment to
China that were there to stay we have
5000 years of patience that we are
hiring really great people we did the
right thing by building a company to
last rather than the tactical thing of
making money quickly whether we're
building great products innovating
according to a global formula and that
we have trust and empowerment from the
headquarters so these are the reasons
that I think we'll be successful in
China thank you
you